Film Courage: Kathie, what are some fatal
errors that a writer should avoid at all costs?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: [Laughs] Wow!
I think one of the things is that you need
to know that it’s not just one script.
You have to think about your whole career,
that you don’t just bank all your hopes
on this one piece of material, that you have
to be working constantly and that things don’t
happen just like that.
One of the things I did in my book was I took
a survey.
I asked all of writers who came into the studios
and that I worked with a couple questions.
And I asked them…and one of them was “How
long did it take you?
And how many scripts did you have to write
before something major happened like you got
an agent, you got an option or somebody bought
something?”
I interviewed over 200 professional writers.
These are not waiter writers.
These are professional writers.
Only one got her script sold…the first script!
Film Courage: Wow…Kathie Fong Yoneda: And
she said it took her five years to get a second
sale.
And the average actually turned out to be
eight tor nine [scripts].
Film Courage: Eight or nine….?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: Scripts.
So you have to love what you do.
You don’t want to be a one-script-wonder.
It doesn’t happen very often where somebody
only writes one script and then that’s it
and then nothing.
They have to be writing constantly.
And that is what agents, executives and producers
are looking for.
They want to build a relationship.
You’ll notice that people like Spielberg
and all the big directors.
They all have the same credits.
All the same people for cinematographer, script
supervisor, and they go to some of the same
writers because they have built a relationship
with them.
Because they like their kind of storytelling.
Their characters speak the same kind of language
that they would like to convey to movie viewers.
And so being able to have those kind of relationships,
it’s not just writing, it’s also writing
the kind of things that are going to continue
that relationship.
So I love the fact that most of the writers
nowadays have a better understanding and now
when I see them at Scriptfest or Great American
Pitchfest…when I ask them…I always ask
them “What else are you working on?”
just to test them nowadays most of them will
say that they have more than one.
So I guess it’s working.
I guess they are getting used to wanting to
have more than one piece of material.
Question for the Viewers: How many scripts
have you written?